Once upon a time, when this town was still a village,
8 minutes
came from nowhere.
The people of the village say that Nu must be the messenger of the god of dogs
.
Let me explain too.
According to one theory, the third god, who is neither a dog nor a cat, appeared at the end, and the god of Taiyama, the god of
light, died and died.
Anyway, the residents
believe in either Inugami or Kanekogami, and the conflict between them is a festival, so there are two ways to call them
.  It seems that dog people and cat people are pouring in from that country I'm a
mail-order cat, right?
This festival is a fight festival.
But Ba, if you're from Shinichi's country, you've probably heard of it.